in 1964 tezuka osamu the father of manga
and author of astro boy wrote a chapter
called the greatest robot on earth
in this story a sultan built a robot
with the purpose of becoming the king of
all robots and by proxy ruler over the
modern world
but in order to achieve that dream this
evil horned creation
first had to triumph against the seven
most powerful robots on earth including
our hero astro boy
what ensued rapidly escalated from a
mere fight between robots into a grand
battle with the fate of the world at
stake as most stories of this type do
but just as much as tezuka osamu's work
can be labeled as shonenuken manga
stories made for young teens it can also
be argued that his repertoire holds all
of the ingredients needed for a much
darker and thematically remarkable story
as well
japanese textbooks even note the vast
array of deeper sub-genres his stories
explore
religion fine arts the universe
even going into osama's unabashed
discussions of the importance of life
futility of war
and the future of humankind
in the appropriate context even a story
so reminiscent of childhood nostalgia
and the ambition of a young boy could
certainly be twisted into a dark tale
and nearly 40 years later naoki
urasawa's melancholic brooding
reimagining of the greatest robot on
earth proved just that
in the murder mystery named after the
story's monstrous killer robot seeking
world domination
[Music]
what is uniquely interesting about pluto
is that though it might be chronicled in
the annals of time being known as a
masterfully warped reimagining of one of
tezuka osamu's greatest stories
i didn't know this context at all before
i read it
after i saw that pluto was only eight
volumes notably shorter and more tightly
plotted than any of naoki urasawa's
other more famous works like monster and
20th century boys
all i expected coming into this story
was another incredible suspenseful and
contemplative crowning literary piece to
add to urasawa's collection
and before i knew the background of this
story and after
that is still exactly what i got
though the original framework of this
manga should i say was built by the late
tezuka osamu urasawa fleshed out the
greatest man on earth in nearly every
way to create pluto to accommodate for
his darker style and unique prowess as a
mangaka
in his rendition this future take on our
world has developed robots just as
advanced if not more than humans
laws exist to protect robot rights even
blurring the line between them being
obedient servants to humans and being
their own equal autonomous inhabitants
of earth
but this advanced world is also in
recovery a great war in central asia was
incited in response to a rebellious
country's secret development of
immensely destructive robots
and ironically the rest of the world
sent their own robots believed to be
invincible unflinching and emotionless
the perfect tools for war
to massacre the entirety of this country
that got a bit too ahead of themselves
the seven most powerful robots in the
world were tasked with the job
mont blanc the beloved lumberjack and
heart of mother nature
north 2 a reclusive butler
heracles and brando the strongest
wrestlers on earth
epsilon a photon powered pacifist
gesekt a europol detective known for his
unrivaled deduction abilities
and of course adam or astro boy
after this war people of earth now sit
in a capricious state of both
gratefulness and reverence towards
robots like adam for being the forefront
of technology and embodiment of human
heroism
and also hatred towards robots as they
infringe closer and closer
onto the precipice of what makes us
humans unique
[Music]
in urasawa's pluto rather than pushing
adam as the narrative center of the
story as you would expect of a remake of
an astro boy comic rosawa actually tells
most of the story through gesekte the
detective an appropriate shift for this
mystery thriller take on pluto's battle
to become the greatest robot on earth
gesick the detective investigates the
string of unprecedented robot related
murders that pluto leaves in his
destructive wake beginning with the
beloved but still extremely powerful
robot mont blanc
all of the victims are adorned with
horns a symbol of the roman god of the
underworlds pluto and a suitable serial
killer-esque motif added in by urasawa
while gesic battles his own internal
monsters and comes to terms with what it
means to be a robot in society gesig
must also find and understand the horror
that is pluto one that he slowly
realizes is targeting him and the other
greatest robots on earth as well
in a scheme that is much greater than
anyone could have anticipated
pluto is a complex story i would argue
that it's urasawa's most complex that
i've read which could be due to the fact
that the majority of his worked on this
project went into thinking about how he
can expand on osama's original plot
without having to write that foundation
himself
pluto is very much its own iceberg at
the tip of the iceberg is the summation
of the knowledge of most people the fact
that pluto is a remake of an old astro
boy story arc small details like that
while a massive submerged part holding
societal subtexts and urasawa's own
philosophical flair
lies below the surface of it all
in fact i don't think that i alone could
fully encapture all of this in one video
i've provided a few great articles to
read about the series to understand it
further in the description which i read
through in an attempt to at least make a
dent on this titanic iceberg myself
but i will certainly attempt it and one
of the most pronounced and ever-present
themes permeating this story defining
the shifting balance between human and
robot and the most important when
attempting to present all of the other
ideas in pluto
is
[Music]
frustration great hatred hatred so
strong it could cause one to kill a man
these things nurture an ai
only a wrong mind can be perfect
this line from dr tenma the creator of
adam in the story takes a lot to unpack
at the end of the day we must remember
what this story is about
the greatest robot on earth
moving past jessica osamu's simple idea
of the greatest robot being the
strongest one of them all rosawa also
integrates our modern debates on what
makes technology great
what can be summed up as their ability
to imitate or transcend human function
pluto discusses this idea to a much
greater depth than most manga that touch
on this idea
for example in this story numerous laws
have been made to protect robot rights
crime against robots is just as illegal
as it is against humans and more so than
anything in pluto
robots have
emotion
typical robot stories delve into the gap
between humans and robots as this
ability to feel emotion but pluto does
the opposite and looks at what happens
when that gap separating them disappears
adam guessed all of the seven greatest
robots were created to imitate human
nature
humans hate they feel sadness so a
perfect robot should be able to do these
things as well
in a way this story reverts robots to
more of a different race than humans
rather than a lower species
there were subtle hints showing this and
there are also more obvious ones like
extremely on-the-nose comparisons of
anti-robot organizations to racial
supremacy groups
but i digress and i return to urasawa's
discussion of how a robot being a exact
imitation of a human what technically
makes them perfect is a contradiction in
and of itself
a robot kills a human at the beginning
of pluto's story and people begin
questioning its ai in response
throughout the rest of it
what went wrong
how is it possible that it killed a
human when robots are specifically coded
not to
wasn't it supposed to be perfect
and that is exactly the problem actually
as adam notes
a perfection that kills people
isn't that a human
that robot killing a person did not make
him any less perfect but actually better
than other robots because it is now even
closer to being human
when a robot begins to surpass its own
code even show emotion and its own
volition it becomes in a sense
perfect
it is quite ironically a flawless
imitation
of the very imperfect human
the humans in this story create robots
in their own image and strive to make
them indistinguishable from us but then
are surprised when they begin expressing
human traits of their own
this story is so dark because it makes
it clear that humankind's idea of right
and wrong perfect and imperfect is
severely skewed
the main cast of seven robots actually
feel like the morally best characters in
the entire series
until we slowly see them show more and
more humanity hatred and sorrow
and their pursuit of perfection i
suppose reversely becomes a horrible
sight to behold
urasawa masterfully shifts this balance
and makes us favor the robots rather
than humans
and nothing in this story embodies that
horror of humanity more than its
discussion of
[Music]
tezuka usamu first began his career as a
mangaka in 1947 in the years following
the second great world war and a period
of both immense strife and postwar
recovery for japan
it makes sense why this same background
being added to pluto would be an
appropriate homage to his work
robot stories typically glorify them as
machines of war tools for utter
destruction
but once again because pluto uniquely
gives its robots emotions or at least a
semblance of them and the ability to
fuel them it sheds an entirely different
light when they're sent to war
in central asia the mountain of corpses
that the seven sat upon after being
called the supposed victors were not
just robot bodies to them not just bits
and pieces of mechanical parts but their
own kind
it's even sadder than normal human war
because in this case the robots didn't
have any choice
adam guessex heracles mont blanc they
were pitted against the robots that a
rogue nation created they were forced to
commit genocide against their own kind
without say or volition in the matter
they were given enormous power
only for them to have to use it to
slaughter their own race
to punish a country from making weapons
of mass destruction the rest of the
world used those same very weapons
against them
is this
peace
there is nothing more futile in my
opinion than that repeating cycle of
hatred at the hands of humanity
osamu in the original story actually
includes a quote about this addressing
the seven most powerful robots asking
them
when will they sit in judgment of the
humans who created temporary life out of
a limitless lust for power and control
and then destroyed it
an important detail to note about our
seven main robots is that even though
they experience emotion
they don't understand it
heracles exists as a robot wrestler
after the war but finds that he can no
longer bring himself to destroy his
opponents as they normally do
questioning whether this is what humans
call pity
mont blanc questions what he's done as
he sits upon a battlefield of corpses
feeling what we might call regret
this is important to note because we as
readers feel such compassion towards
these poor beings who've been
manipulated into acting on the behalf of
humans
given the feeling of pain sorrow and
hatred that come with it
but aren't able to process it for what
it is
it's as if humans want to create robots
exactly like them and to create another
form of human but then continue to treat
them as nothing more than an
amalgamation of
parts it's how urasawa paints the robots
as the best characters in pluto and his
ability to expose humanity for his
horrors
that creates one of the deepest stories
i've ever read and one of the best ways
to honor the legacy of the father of
manga himself
despite being a rehashing of an old
story pluto still stands proud among
urasawa's other manga as an impressive
piece of literature it's the kind of
story where i think reading it multiple
times would greatly benefit anyone
seeking to fully understand its societal
implications and message for the world
it is the perfect example of what occurs
when two of the greatest minds come
together
and make something truly
beautiful
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses